un dialogue efficace possible avec le
président américain vladimir poutine
s'en est dit convaincu les deux
dirigeants doivent s'entretenir
aujourd'hui par téléphone sur la crise
ukrainienne joe biden devrait proposer
une voie diplomatique à son homologue
russe le chef du kremlin a affirmé
vouloir résoudre lui aussi cette crise
par la négociation
et pour en parler nous retrouvons notre
correspondante à moscou maylis d'estrées
bonjour maylis captant le kremlin de ces
pourparlers
bonjour stefan visiblement beaucoup
puisque c'est à l'initiative du
président russe qu aura lieu cet
entretien téléphonique avec joe biden
moins d'un mois après la première
visioconférence entre les deux
dirigeants le kremlin souhaite ainsi
préparer les négociations russo
américaines
ce l'ukraine et la sécurité en europe
qui se dérouleront ce 10 janvier à
genève écoutez
depuis la dernière conversation la
russie comme promis à formuler sa
position qui a été énoncé dans les
projets des deux documents qui ont été
portées à l'attention de washington et
d'un certain nombre de capitales
européennes
et donc maintenant bien sûr de notre
point de vue du point de vue du
président poutine il faut mener une
autre conversation téléphonique qui
précéderait le début des négociations
susmentionnés
toute négociation quelle qu'elle soit
nous somme n'est qu'avec un seul
objectif parvenir à un compromis en
tenant compte des positions de principe
des uns et des autres
en tête des revendications russe
l'interdiction de tout élargissement
futur de l'otan vers l'est ainsi que la
fin des manoeuvres militaires
occidentales près des frontières de la
russie la maison blanche veut elle que
les troupes russes s'éloigne de la
frontière ukrainienne écoutez
la russie n'a jamais été une source de
tension et n'a jamais été la source
première détention mais nous avons
toujours dit que la russie prenait et
continuerait de prendre les mesures
nécessaires afin d'assurer sa sécurité
nous sommes prêts à mener un dialogue
nous le voulons nous pensons que la
seule voie des négociations permettra de
résoudre les problèmes pressants qui
existe entre nous en grand nombre
[Musique]
bien entendu les déplacements de nos
forces armées sur notre territoire son
autre prérogative exclusive
vous savez qu'il existe différentes
opinions à ce sujet notamment parmi les
représentants des autorités ukrainiennes
il dit au contraire qu'il ne constate
aucune accumulation extraordinaire de
troupes russes près de la frontière ce
qui provoquerait l'inquiétude du côté
ukrainien il faut prendre en compte de
telles déclarations aussi
dans ses voeux de nouvel an adressé ce
mercredi au président américain vladimir
poutine s'est dit convaincu qu'un
dialogue constructif et fondé sur le
respect mutuel était possible entre
moscou et washington
merci maïlys destrée à moscou